plusieurs des mères majoritairement nous
évoquent qu'elles ont été victimes de
violences conjugales parfois
majoritairement en présence de l'enfant
sauf que le cadre légal ne leur permet
pas de leur d'opposer aux parents dit
auteurs une interdiction de rentrer en
contact ou d'héberger l'enfant qui a été
témoin de violence conjugale
il y a toujours une une tension entre le
droit des familles et les droits de
l'enfant c'est à dire entre le droit des
parents et les droits de l'enfant et
cette tension elle est elle s'exprime
souvent par une une idéologie
familialiste qui qui fait que on a une
difficulté à protéger véritablement
l'enfant cette loi elle apporte une
avancée dans le sens où on se centre et
on se recentre sur l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant un des grands problèmes que
nous rencontrons souvent c'est que
l'enfant peut se taire parce que si les
confrontés tous les week-ends
il n'a pas l'assurance qu'il sera
protégé et parfois sa parole va venir
d'autant plus l'exposer donc on est nous
en tant que professionnel parfois dans
une position de complicité indirecte qui
nous permet pas de manière juridique de
véritablement protéger l'enfant les sur
les enfants nous le savons des
répercussions très graves notamment sur
leur développement leur santé leur
construction leur scolarité et leur vie
sociale pour bien grandir un enfant a
besoin que l'on réponde à ses besoins
fondamentaux dont la sécurité physique
et affective
lors de question je rassure tout le
monde de retirer l'autorité parentale ou
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale à un
ensemble de français mais dans les cas
les plus graves ça paraît nécessaire de
mieux protéger l'enfant et qu'il n'aille
pas en week-end chez un père agresseur
si on prend les questions d'inceste que
s'il y a eu un féminicide ben en fait
que l'enfant puisse vivre une vie
complexe qui nécessite aussi du soin
mais qui soit accompagné et qui puisse
vivre une vie d'enfants et c'est quand
même particulièrement c'est vrai ça des
enfants dans les cas les plus graves et
ils auront besoin d'accompagnement
psychique et psychiatrique parfois donc
c'est vraiment le prendre soin en tout
cas des enfants et c'est ce que j'essaye
de faire